ciao ragazze per realizzare il tutorial
di oggi ho usate questi tre pennelli
quindi procuratevi anche voi
no non è un tutorial e un video sulle
ragazze quando si truccano aspettativa è
in realtà perché ho deciso di fare
questo video perché tanti di noi sono
molto brave a truccarsi tante altre non
ci riguardano tutto questo tutorial ha
comunque insomma devono migliorare un po
ho deciso di fare un video per tutte e
due queste categorie e lo divisa in
sezioni quindi a seconda della parte del
nostro viso dobbiamo giocare
buona visione
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e
l'acqua forse rivedere storia ragazzi
da un po e tokai ha però la moda
sì
grazie o mio dio dedico questa vittoria
di marco
governo sempre sostenuta temi comprato
tutti gli istituti vale una vita
occhio però questo è più sottile qui ai
lager e smokey eye che un colpo solo
[Musica]
sì pronta carissima e similari stuprato
per spacciato video sentiamo dopo
ciao ciao ciao ragazze spero nel video
vi sia piaciuto volevo farvi vedere gli
8 centri scatti di cotone che ho usato
nomi sono bloccate su 700 volte ho la
faccia fucsia prima spero per video vi
sia piaciuto mi sono divertita molto a
girarlo comodo dare un bellissimo video
e come al solito si è piaciuto me rete
laica iscriviti al canale e seguite
visto tutti gli altri social instagram
facebook slacciate musicali e comunque
do adoro
[Musica]